welcome back to the morning toast we are
so excited because jackie and i run in a
fabulous circle of people and we are
honored and humbled to be joined with
the og fabulous woman jill zarin welcome
to the toad
thank you
we have an audience
uh every one of them is entourage
thank you so much for being here well
thank you for having me so the girl with
no job has a really good job i never
heard that before you are classified
you've heard that every single time
every day of my life every day yeah i
know um we love you like we think you i
mean i rewatched real housewives of new
york during the pandemic and i always
knew i was a jail girly like i was team
jill till i died all that but
re-watching i was watching in high
school what the [ __ ] did i know
re-watching it over the pandemic like i
had such a new respect for you i loved
you on the show and now you're here
obviously you're promoting real
housewives ultimate girls trip and i'm
so happy that you're back on tv because
you are really thankful and truly made
for it well i'm really here promoting
jill and ally
ultimate girls trip is just a vehicle as
we've seen on the show
to promote my [ __ ] yeah and that's all
good you there's like a trope that you
are always like hawking something new
right oh well if you've seen if you i
don't want to have a spoiler alert but
if you've watched episodes one two and
or actually two and three
um um you know the girls learn right
away that i have a lot of stuff going on
i've got a lot of products i'm selling
and i give a lot of stuff to the girls
and i i don't you know what it's so part
of my dna
that
i was wearing a shirt that i never made
it was just a sample and i'm like oh it
was it was um it was a tennis sweatshirt
and it said i think it's a camp zarin
hamptons or something it's a hampton
shirt and i said oh you know what this
is mine because i was wearing it and and
then they did on the tv you know choo
choo ching and then they made a logo
jay-z tv like qvc jay-ztv which i
actually now made a t-shirt on my
website joezaaron.com in my merch yes
and of course i brought all my swag to
give you as gifts oh we're so excited we
love it don't you love swag we also like
have so much shopjill and ali stuff like
i have everything the phone charms the
jewelry so we'll take more but your
stuff is really premium yeah
oh dude where's my dice i have this
sweatshirt that says where's my diet she
wears it all the time if you drink it
we'll give you one of these yes you know
i'm always with my diet coke is there
diet coke in there what do you think
what are your thoughts on diet pepsi
nope really nope not unless they pay me
a lot of money
i actually love diet pepsi i think more
than diet coke do you really i know it's
like a weird thing i recently discovered
about myself and i've had fights with
people in restaurants owners about it
where they tried to like slide it in and
tell me it's like coke and i know it's
not and we have to fight about it um
zach on main street in in the hamptons
you know he's got a new show serving yes
yeah he and i got into a big time a
couple years ago and i won he actually
called me up one day and said uh it
wasn't a pepsi diet coke thing it was a
coke diet coke thing they served me
uh diet coke but it was coke and i knew
it was coke i'm like this is not diet
don't even try and i'm like take me
downstairs he takes me downstairs he
shows me all the boxes that it's because
i first i said it's fake coke or it's
coconut zero whatever yeah he shows me
the box it's actually me it's a brown
box and it has the label on it i mean
you'd have to work really hard to fake
that stuff yeah um so i go downstairs
everything is right but i said to him
listen they must have switched it this
is there's a switch in the lines he's
like jill they just put it in last week
i said i'm telling you do what you want
i'm telling you a month later he calls
me up he goes i have to tell you the guy
came in you know to service to fill us
up you're right there was a mistake they
switched it no you a true diet coke
connoisseur knows when it's not diet
don't even try and i could tell fountain
from canada that's what i was talking
about from bottle i mean i code what is
your preferred method of diet coke is it
fountain is it bottle is it can is it
glass bottle bottle plastic bottle the
big one is the best because it leaves
you lose the least amount of fuzz in it
because there's only this much air at
the top it's like champagne kind of
thing i'm a real connoisseur but but
it's really about the ice people agreed
what's your favorite ice
um you know i like the cube
i do but i have two ice makers one in
each house like i have one that's cuban
and one that's small i like them both i
like the little nuggets the nugget yeah
the nugget makers actually the more
expensive ice yes i know we're waiting
for prime day to get one let's see what
was the ice situation at jorina's house
there was no ice situation
there was a lot of no situation
well we were just talking about that
without
right like so you know ultimate girls
trip first time they went to turks and
caicos gorgeous villa i hear the next
one is somewhere really fancy like bali
or something uh yes it is not bali but
yes it is you went to someone's house in
the berkshires and it's a gorgeous
gorgeous house which is gorgeous but did
you feel like a little like
like slighted did you watch the episode
i said i did
uh i think they used actually you know
we all get interviewed we all get asked
a lot of the same questions and of
course they had to use mine so dorinda
probably hates me right uh no i don't
think she hates me but um yeah i said
and i'm sure she by the way dorinda
would say the same thing like why my
house why couldn't i go to turks and
canada right i have to work so hard she
did work hard she let me okay
tonight's episode tomorrow night's
episode is um
according to uh the executive producer
of all housewives shows in all cities
told one of our uh producer one of the
producers on our particular in our
company who makes it that it's the best
episode she's ever seen of all
housewives shows which i think is
overstated to be honest i don't think
that i don't know that because i haven't
seen every episode of every show
but and i was in it but it's a lot of me
it's definitely circles around my story
line with dorinda of how i met her and
kind of like the evolution
and
it's uh allie what'd you think ali saw
it
it's kind of must-watch yeah no i
thought it was great right ally thinks
it's great deeper looking to you and all
of us all of us too did you have
anything to do with dorinda getting on
the show originally like
no no i i i definitely brought it to the
event with the mindset that i would love
her to be on the show but nothing ever
happened from that and then years later
ramon actually brought her on got it
yeah what does it feel like to do it
again like there's been such a long time
since you were on it's like i never left
really well you know i'm still friends
with the girls and i never you know in
spite of what you hear from people and a
lot of it's like you know haters rumors
whatever you know i never self-produced
myself i mean sure i would come up with
ideas for scenes and things like that
you have to otherwise you don't have a
show but i kind of just never see the
cameras
i just let it rip
one way or the other i think i'm i'm
actually probably if anything more
edited now than i was back then um
because i don't want to hurt people's
feelings i think i'm a little bit more
it's a different time too it's just a
different time no but not even that i
probably would say something that's
inappropriate if i thought it was
important it's more that i'm sensitive
to other people's feelings yeah you know
a little bit more so i don't think i'm
as hardcore and that's what you're going
to see
on the episode
tomorrow night morning when you you were
constantly being brought up on the new
york franchise long after you were gone
um did that bother you in the sense that
you couldn't respond or like defend
yourself or just give your input
well if it was something that i would
want to yes but most of the time i was
flattered yeah you know that they didn't
forget me i mean a lot of housewives
have come and gone but i yeah i feel
like i never i think people who don't
watch the show on a regular basis still
think i'm on
yeah i mean if they don't watch on a
regular basis right so you know i kind
of kept myself relevant
definitely i really wanted like i don't
think you ever spoke about it on social
media but there was a huge storyline
that bethany used bobby's funeral for a
photo op and they really kind of went
after her and i would be beyond curious
to hear what your thoughts on that were
you know i don't want to go there to be
honest um it's it's it's it's done yeah
um i don't want to rehash it again
i can just say that
um
i don't blame bethany really i mean i
think she it was nice that she came i
was happy to see her i was definitely
caught off guard with the filming um
they what i would like to say that's
important is because people don't know
this i was not paid
to be honest to be on that episode i was
never offered to be on the episode i was
never in you know given a release to be
on the episode i was never told i would
be on television that season it was a
big surprise to me when i was on the
commercial every day wow outside the
funeral home with bethany talking i had
no idea but um i'm happy that bobby was
honored yeah he was definitely a big
part of the show huge um i think part of
it was maybe a misunderstanding but once
there was a misunderstanding they still
didn't like make a donation make it
right and make it right with me or with
the family or whatever but you know what
i'm back on television i'm in a great
place with bravo i don't hold any
grudges
i think i've evolved to that place where
i just like keep moving keep it going
forward that's really mature
and i'm not even saying it like i'm
saying it just to say it right i
wouldn't say it if i didn't mean it you
know i couldn't say it if you didn't
mean it because yeah you would you know
i'm lying you're not a very good liar
yeah
not a good i can't keep you know what it
is i can't lie cause i don't remember
that's me like literally yeah and people
think i'm lying i'm like i literally
have no idea what you're talking about
your truth it's my truth like what are
you talking about and he's restaurants
like when i go back on the show i'm like
every single day and no one believes me
they first of all i hate the word
thursday i have to say i'm hungry
not thirsty and i'm hungry so everyone
has to stop telling me i'm thirsty
because i'm starving do people call you
thirsty frequently um some people do
they like to just uh dorinda like to
poke me with that like you're thirsty to
be back on the show yeah and it really
bothers me and i don't know why it
really bothers me it hits a nerve i
guess because it's not true right and
you're very fulfilled
i have a really great life and just
because and i say you know you can't um
you know don't you're projecting
yourself on me
um you don't like that thou does protest
too much that kind of thing like stop
calling me thirsty you're thirsty no
yeah i mean like i'm good
and you know people ask me if i want to
go back on the show when i give an
answer it's always the answer i feel
today sometimes i say be great sometimes
i say i can never go back right
sometimes i say it really depends it
depends on who's on it depends on when
it is depends on how much money they're
willing to pay right you know i never
made a lot of money on the show this
will be the time to make money and if
it's not why do it i saw a clip of you
on a podcast where you shared like back
then you were making what seven thousand
dollars i made seventy seven thousand to
seven five hundred the first season
right then five thousand for the reunion
that's insane and then like the second
season it was you know more but not much
more i really didn't start to make some
money until the fourth season then i was
you know gone yeah yeah
speaking of the rhony legacy that's
coming out have you spoken to anyone
about doing that you know who's going to
be participating i have i know as much
as you do what do you think about
probably no more what do you think about
doing the two shows like as a concept
solution to what happens well i think
they're playing it safe i think they're
making a backup plan yeah rather than be
off the air four years then start with
an or two years and then start with a
new crew by the time it gets filmed and
out now you've lost another year from
when you saw the ogs
and if it fails you have to wait another
year to recast and do it again i think
that they don't want to lose the
audience completely and never get them
back so i think that they're kind of
hedging their bet however
i don't know if that's a done deal it's
not done for me
so if they you know it's not done for me
it's not done for bethany for sure alex
and simon are living their life in
australia can we talk about that because
when i was re-watching um
the early seasons of housewives during
the pandemic i remember in high school
like thinking oh my god alex and simon
are like not okay they're insane and
then seeing it again
as an adult like i very much had the
same sentiment um but i really actually
do feel like they're really nice people
and that's what i gather like even
though they're
on the show they were like a little off
i gather that they're nice people and
i'm and now they have this like totally
different life in australia she's like a
psychologist she became she got her and
i'm not empty she got a phd in
psychology and he became a lawyer it's a
different it's a different um uh
education it doesn't stop the
traditional united states but it's
definitely still a lawyer um and it's
the kids have grown up and they're tall
and like amazing and um
you know it was such a different time
then
i was shocked that they fired them i
think it was a huge mistake me too i
think they ruined the show at the time i
did i thought it then i still think now
that it never recovered never recovered
it's like lori yeah because it's quite
interesting want to go back and watch it
because you only have four years of us
together really three with bethany and
then she left but i thought it was great
when she left not great when she left
but meaning that the show was still
great without her and then they just
destroyed it for no reason for no reason
the ratings were great they were making
tons of money and i never i still don't
have a straight answer why but i was
with kristen takeman last night for
dinner and she was on it she was one of
the people who came on after i left and
she said that um they actually i don't
remember this she says they took like a
year off at some point after she was on
or before she was on because the show
had done so badly when it came back with
all these new people that it never
really recovered and what are alex and
simon's feelings about their time on the
show did they love it did they hate it
do they regret it i think they regret it
yeah i think they were good they had to
move they had to leave the country right
but i think their life is great now me
too
the circumstances that they had to leave
were great at all yeah um he couldn't
get a job here wow yeah it was really
hard but i have to say you know simon
was like
a monster
to me i had for no reason honest to god
allie was there no reason no reason i
didn't do it it was he it you know what
it just infiltrated all our lives and we
just all became full of ourselves and
didn't had a handle being famous and
nobody was telling us what to do nobody
had you know it's just there was no
other celebrities to talk to that did
what we did there was no other
housewives or husbands to talk to we
were the first yeah and we paid a big
price for that in a lot of ways uh but
there's some great things that come with
being the og of course yeah and it's
before everything is like formulaic
where it is now instagram yeah right we
had to do blogs just talk to you
we had to do blogs here from right you
know yeah it was crazy um personally i
think why i've always felt connected to
you is because new york is such a jewish
city
and there aren't that many jewish
housewives of new york if i i don't
think you and heather
right was heather jewish or half jewish
heather is jewish but i don't think um
i think i don't think bethany's jewish
you know your mike is fine yeah it's
fine
okay um
and when you were introduced on ultimate
girls trip they're like jill's not here
she's
doing a jewish holiday which just like
made me so happy and i said i'm a jew
yeah like it's and i'm proud to be a jew
we love that we love that and there's
really not a lot of jewish yeah claps
for jews
good for the jews
but like there's really not a lot of new
york jews or like jewish representation
on the real housewives of new york which
i find to be so bizarre because it's
such a jewish city and they don't care
right no they don't it's so weird to me
it is what it is well now lea is a jew
too well leah yeah leah just converted
you know leah i i met her like once or
twice she's nice i think she might stay
on the show i think she's going to end
up on the new the new i do i think
they're going to hold on to one person i
think that would work i do if she brings
on a cool crowd even though she was here
saying she wanted to go to legacy like
with her friends
oh i don't know if all our friends are
going to legacy i mean and and the other
thing about legacy it's like what is a
legacy is is legacy only the original
four years where the four of us were
together meaning kelly and sonia
whatever or is legacy anybody who's been
on more than two years his legacy
i don't know
question i do think sonia would qualify
as a legacy i do too yeah i think kelly
does too yeah yeah i forgot about kelly
oh how could you forget about kelly
are you kidding me we better erase this
and do that like who is she talking
about of course i follow kelly benson on
tick tock don't i was with her this
weekend that's so nice like that i'm
still friends with you know a lot louis
right oh my god yes kelly luanne sonya
ramona is in my building i live in her
old apartment what yes i found out she
came over last week and she told me that
she used to live in that apartment
before when she was married before she
married mario i think they were living
together before they got married oh yeah
isn't that crazy please yeah it is i
mean so it's just crazy and you know
we're in a good place then we're not in
a great place and we're in a good place
it's just nothing changes that's what's
so great yeah there's not not much has
changed in the 15 years as far as the
relationships between us no but it's
like everything in the world changes but
ramona and jill are forever i know and
that's you know so it's unfortunate
everything works out the way it's
supposed to yeah the truth is now i'm so
fulfilled i work with my beautiful
daughter ali yes a friend of yours clap
and a fan of yours well you like made a
lot of waves during the pandemic because
you started your own business and at
first it was like scrappy in your living
room and now it's like a full fledge can
alley come in
come i want to yeah i want to show you
guys what we've been doing and you
brought gifts which we it's a great it's
a great way to get invited back we are
the swag queens swag queens that's
important ali can you do it cause i'm
kind of sunk in here can you end with
the dog and the mic can you show us oh
show us yes yes you show jill talk whose
is whose yeah that's good whoever you
guys can trade this show that's nice
that's that's the exact line that i
thought would be good for the baby oh
that's so good
yeah
a baby
you are a baby i know how old 29 oh my
god yeah i had ellie at 29. you look
like a baby you look like a baby though
congratulations oh my god did you have a
girl a boy a boy oh
look how great these are here show
them so
[Music]
the other night i literally was oh my
god i love that that's a great beach bag
it's just a great little bag so cute you
know i have this beach bag in other
colors
yeah you do candles
oh i have some of your candles in my
house i have sweatshirts manifestations
everything we have by the way we have
the best bravo swag better because you
do any better
i mean come on our our new york
established beverly hills established
and then you know we did a tagline for
each of the girls from the ultimate
girls trip and i gave each one of them a
sweatshirt with their tagline and some
of them wore it around the house we'll
see if it shows up right and it even had
like we went you know most of the time
you can get a printed sweatshirt
whatever we embroidered the apple or the
diamond or the peach on the sleeve we
avoided it so it like gave it a little
bit of special some of them even have
the episode it came from on the sleeve
so you know people ask us a lot like how
do you guys work together you don't kill
each other i can never work with my
sister but you guys are in business
together now and i'm curious if you
prefer it to being in business with
strangers or it's better or worse
would you like to answer that sure can
you hear me yeah yeah you're just
talking um i think
you know i worked in corporate before
covid and because of circumstances i was
like oh for my job like a lot of other
people
and we never would have probably planned
for this and i always distance myself
from the housewives and from reality tv
to like do my own career my own past
like on my own
like i never brought up
no she never was it hard
like being a kid no this is what i want
to know was it hard being a kid in the
city going to high school with your mom
on the show before it was like
universally accepted as cool back when
it was like guilty pleasure it was
really hard it was really embarrassing
really you guys were in the city i'm
sure you heard rumors and when nyc prep
started yeah
yeah i could have seen you on nyc prep
thank god she did so agreed um because
they wanted this like fantasy of gossip
girl irl right but you can't do that
it's not how it is
drinking yeah right um
but yeah it was embarrassing i mean
instagram didn't exist which probably
would have made it worse yeah
existed we were in high school yeah um
but i think and even now still it's a
guilty pleasure the people are
embarrassed to still talk about that i
watch the housewives my guilty pleasure
like it's our secret for the girls night
um so i still think there's a sigma
around it but now that everyone like is
their own boss and has their own
platform it's definitely more normalized
and common
what happened to those girls from new
york city prep do we know
there's a deep dive on it um some of
them got married some of them are off
the grid um
it's very unclear because they're
married they don't have huge social
media and if they do they're private wow
yeah he got married kelly sebastian got
married oh really yeah yeah
i'm married sebastian that was such a
crazy time but you guys like working
together yes was the original question i
think that we both bring stuff to the
table that's very different um like i
lean on her more for like being the yes
or no person the final answer and i kind
of like
do everything else like the um
the actual like groundwork the dirty
work like getting you know really really
dirty alley does the dirty on her to be
like is it approved or not approved like
yes or no you do the big phone calls the
big accounts like
you're you're you come in
i'm sales face of in a lot of ways and
then ali digs in so like we'll have a
big meeting with a corporate with a big
customer and their president or whatever
and we'll have a conversation and then
when it gets trickled down to the buyer
or whatever then ali goes to work and
ally gets involved and does the details
writes the orders make sure it follows
the shipping and all that but get but i
source the goods i place the orders um
finances i pay for everything
so i have to have three other jobs to do
that right right right and then you know
we have a great team alyssa and bailly
are here and we've got our team injury
we have a warehouse in new jersey and
connecticut um i'm based in boca so
that's where i am most of the time uh so
you know we're busy
and you're doing this whole time now
ellie full time and that's jill and ally
then i have my rugs which i have two of
them in my house i have to say
nothing is easier to clean up dog piss
then and i vacuum so well there's not a
single stain on it i've had it for four
years
from wayfair it is one of my favorite
rugs and i probably will never buy
another rug that's not jill's aaron i
swear to god and i am not coming
thank you we're working on our next line
for next year i'm working on a hamptons
collection amazing we need one in the
studio
i mean at that prince the collection i
think we have it already in the printed
collection we have some more collections
coming out i just came out so we have
our cleanable rugs indoor and outdoor
that are dog and pee and everything but
i also have a higher end a little bit of
wool do not have an animal if you want
bull rugs like i could put it here
because you don't really have anything
yes
we do
but i have a pink and white rug that's
perfect for this send it well you need
any red we need a new rug right you need
to you definitely
and i make this in white by the way i do
have this color fabulous and it's and
it's stain proof so it sounds like you
are like us a mogul
ally i'm i i'm pitching her to be thirty
under thirty for four something so bad
that's the bucket list i don't have much
got it that's a bucket list did you guys
know ever we've never done two more
years
well she did a lot of charity during the
pandemic a lot you know
it was a good run so where can everyone
shop shopjill and alley
shopjillynaly.com.com.com for the rugs
the swag but they're both in the top of
the website
but you can toggle oh i love that on the
website
yes she knows she knows bravo toggle and
you can use autry 15 for 15 yeah
oh shy thank you for the gifts that was
literally so nice and unnecessary and
thank you for coming we love watching
you on the new show it's so nice it's
like a piece has been restored in the
universe jill's aaron is waiting for you
see you
calling you you may want me back one
more time after i haven't seen the next
two i saw it tomorrow
it's must watch tomorrow really okay
yeah it's gonna just
expose a lot of things oh wow we love
experience we're gonna have an expo
a lot of questions are gonna get
answered tomorrow i think okay for
people who might be curious about
certain things oh i'm ready for that on
my way thank you guys so much for
listening this uh if you're listening to
the podcast we are back uh tomorrow with
a remote episode so thank you so much
for listening have an amazing day have a
great day and we'll see you tomorrow bye
guys
[Applause]